[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
dire pourquoi est-ce que l'apple watch
et ce et la montre connectez d'apple
qu'il vous faut plutôt qu'une apple
watch série 6 dont je vous ai déjà parlé
il ya quelques jours et pour vous
expliquer ça on a besoin de deux choses
une faille et un crayon vous allez voir
ça va être très très clair on a quatre
différence entre la paloise cher et 6 et
l'apple watch est ce la toute première
ça va être l'écran la numéro deux ce
sont les capteurs la numéro trois c'est
la puce et numéro quatre c'est le prix
et en dehors de ces quelques points qui
sont final pas très important eh bien on
à l'année montre voilà emballé c'est
pesé merci beaucoup en moi c'était
monsieur gros j'espère cette vidéo vous
aura plu pourrait faire comme ça mais en
fait non il ya beaucoup plus de choses à
raconter effectivement on a quatre
points quatre points essentiels de
différence mais au-delà de ces quatre
points c'est vrai qu'après une très très
grosse différence je vous détailler si
vous expliquez vous allez voir qu'on
fait eh bien je pense que l'apple watch
est ce c'est la vraie belle monde
d'apple à cette année la vraie montre
intéressante grand public au delà
quelques usages un peu pointu que je
vais justement venir vous détailler ici
l'écran la watch et ce et l'écran de la
cie ce sont exactement même alors ici
j'ai plus de batterie parce que j'étais
le pam assiste depuis quelques jours
parce que j'utilise la west est ce mais
c'est exactement la même chose
la seule différence que vous allez avoir
entre l'a6 est là et se sait qu'avec
l'a6 vous avez un écran qui est allumée
en permanence tandis que pour la seule
il faudra venir bouger votre monde pour
qu'elle s'allume mais au delà de ça
c'est la même chose la deuxième
différence à se faire au niveau des
capteurs parce que sur la watch est ce
vous n'avez pas de capteur de saturation
d'oxygène sanguin vous ne pouvez pas la
mesurer et vous n'avez pas non plus de
capteurs électriques de fréquence
cardiaque
mais sinon vous avez toujours le capteur
optique de fréquence cardiaque ce qui
veut donc dire qu'avec votre apple watch
et ce il ya deux choses que vous ne
pouvez pas faire que vous pouvez faire
avec votre apple watch série 6 ça va
être mesurée la saturation en oxygène
dans votre sens et ça va être de faire
un électrocardiogramme mais réellement
sa serment entre nous vous le faites ou
pas ou ce que vous pourriez le faire
faire un électrocardiogramme avec votre
montre et mesurer la saturation en
oxygène dans votre sens franchement
simplement bas en commentaire
[Musique]
l'autre différence et la puce puisque
sur la watch est ce vous avez la puce s5
et sur la watch et si vous avez la puce
s6 en réalité vous allez avoir 20 % de
performances en plus avec la s6 et avec
la s5 ce qui vous permettra notamment
d'avoir la fonctionnalité avec l'écran
qui tout le temps allumé sur les six que
vous n'avez pas ici avec l'appui 16,5
bon ok mais après vous avez tout
l'optimisation logicielle de walsh os 7
je vais vous détailler dans quelques
instants que vous retrouvez bien
évidemment sur notre match et se met
également sur vos 3-6 autant dire que
brouiller une différence certes mais
est-elle suffisamment significatives je
vous pose la question vous avez dix
minutes ils ont marqué deux mois en bas
en commentaire et enfin il ya la
question du prix parce que oui ça reste
toujours l'élément le plus important
il ya une vraie différence il faut
savoir que votre apple watch est ce
coûte 299 euros dans le modèle à 40 mm
parce que oui vous avez bien évidemment
modèle 40 mm un modèle 44 mm le modèle
40 mm coût de 299 euros tandis que sur
la watch série 6 elle coûtera 4 129
euros on a quand même un vrai beau delta
et si vous allez sur le modèle
cellulaire votre apple walsh et sur 140
mm vous coûtera 349 euros contre aux 529
euros
et c'est la même chose pour le 44 mm 329
euros soit modèle gps pour votre watch
et ce contre 459 euros sur votre apple
watch série 6 est sur le modèle
cellulaire toujours en 44 mm 379 euros
pour votre watch et ce contre 559 euros
vous avez un vrai delta est une fois de
plus la différence ce sont uniquement
ces quatre points ça peut paraître peu
de choses pour certaines personnes ça
fera une réelle différence mais pour moi
répandre commun des mortels et pour
gérer la majorité des personnes qui vont
vouloir tuer cette montre là eh bien ça
ne changera pas grand chose
[Musique]
et justement c'est très drôle parce que
j'ai retrouvé les notes que j'avais
justement emprise lorsque je travaillais
sur la vidéo de la paloise séries6 java
notamment vu plusieurs catégories de
personnes qui souhaitaient acheter
notamment pour la santé vous a donc à
voir tous les âges santé qui va vraiment
justifiée sur la paloise séries6
notamment pour me refaire votre cg
suivre votre rythme cardiaque voire la
saturation en oxygène dans le sang
prévenir les chutes suivent le sommeil
alors bon mise à part le cg est mise à
part la saturation en oxygène dans le
sang
vous avez tout le reste puisque tout le
reste est avec watch os et que vous avez
exactement le même os avec des
performances qui seront sensiblement
similaire vous sentirez pas réellement
la différence entre une paloise série 6
et une apple watch est ce en tout cas
moi j'ai pas senti vraiment de grosse
différence c'est rien qui m'a vraiment
surpris il ya également toute la partie
exercices physiques vous allez pouvoir
retrouver dans vos deux montres ou là
effectivement il ya absolument aucune
différence donc dans les deux cas ça
fonctionnera très bien puis tout ce que
vous allez avoir pour écouter de la
musique pour l'expérience multimédia
pour piloter votre iphone passer des
appels répondre à un sms et compagnie
bien vous l'aurez dans les deux cadeaux
la vraie grosse différence va se faire
au niveau de l' usage santé donc pour
moi aujourd'hui la paloise chérie si ça
l'est vraiment destiné aux technophiles
aux personnes qui veulent ce qui ce fait
de mieux aujourd'hui en terme de non
connectés aux personnes qui peuvent ou
qui veulent mettre cet argent là dedans
tandis que l'apple watch et ce pour moi
elle va se dessiner plus à tout un
chacun
toutes les personnes qui ont un iphone
et qui veulent la montre qui va avec
dans l'écosystème avec tous les usages
que vous allez pouvoir faire parce que
vous ne faites pas croire nous allait
mesurer très souvent peu de saturation
en oxygène de votre son je ne croirai
pas où vous allez faire très souvent un
électrocardiogramme ça reste très gadget
et pour les personnes qui en ont
réellement besoin je pense qu'elles sont
des dispositifs médicaux chez eux qui
leur permettent de le faire alors je dis
pas que c'est pas un bon outil l'hapoel
syrie six mois je l'adoré je trouve très
bien et c'est vraiment une superbe
montre mais aujourd'hui je dirais que
l'appel watch et celui des maple pions
on va se dire qu'on va plus à l'est sur
une apple watch est ce qui aura
l'essentiel et qui fera tout très bien
puisque les différences ne seront pas
suffisamment fort pour venir justifier
de mettre 150 euros de plus pour passer
sur une apple séries6 mise à part une
fois de plus pour les technophiles et
une fois de plus pour les besoins de
santé et bien parce que ça va toucher
quelques personnes ça va être beaucoup
plus niche et que ce qu'on pourrait le
croire
alors oui effectivement il ya aussi une
différence je vous ai pas parlé parce
que pour moi les pas suffisamment
significative lorsqu'on regarde le prix
parce que si on regarde le prix c'est
qu'on va pas mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans la finition
ici sont apple watch est seul vous
n'aurez qu'une finition et ce qui est
déjà très très bien en aluminium 100%
recyclé les autres finitions vous pouvez
retrouver sur la page web série 6 et
bien vous ne les aurais pas mais si vous
voulez les autres finitions comme vous
coûter quand même beaucoup plus cher et
bien à ce moment là je pense que la
question du prix ne se pose pas
forcément de cette manière là donc ils
seront plus des personnes qui veulent le
dernier produit à la mode avec la
meilleure fiche technique on va être
vraiment dans un mariage entre mode et
technologie une fois de plus on
s'adresse aux technophiles aux
technophiles comme la bonne voilà à mon
avis pour schématiser et je vous le dis
une fois de plus que ce soit la
détection des chutes que ce soit les
appels d'urgence que ce soit tout ce qui
va le sport tout ce qui va être lavage
de mains les appels les sms siri apple
paix vous avez tous avec webos vous avez
dans les deux montrent donc pour moi je
vois pas forcément l'intérêt aujourd'hui
d'aller sur la paloise chéri 6 donc si
vous voulez aujourd'hui une très belle
apple watch si vous voulez un bel objet
si vous voulez la même taille d'écran si
vous voulez les mêmes fonctionnalités
mises à part ces quelques points de
détail qui deviennent aujourd'hui des
points détaillés qui justifie une
différence de 150 euros
et bien la pelle watch et ce je pense
est fait pour vous en tout cas moi je la
donne je trouve vraiment très très bien
a vous de me dire vous maintenant ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi
est ce que pour vous le fait d'avoir
l'écran tout en lui mais c'est
extrêmement important ou pas je vous
dirai pas plus vous bougez votre poignet
votre monde se réactive et vous voyez
leur est ce que le fait de ne pas avoir
ces différents capteurs notamment pour
avoir un électrocardiogramme pour avoir
la saturation en oxygène de votre sang
vous pose problème est ce que pour vous
la différence entre la puce s5 s6
suffisamment significative pour vous
alliez absolument sur l'apple watch
série 6
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire pour moi en tout cas cette
année apple a vraiment faire tout très
intéressant vous proposons une apple
watch qui malgré tout reste un budget un
peu moins de 300 euros ça reste quand
même beaucoup d'argent mais permet de
rendre la pelouse plus accessibles dont
je trouve ça vraiment bien je trouve
très cool en tout cas s'appelle watch et
puis je vous la recommande à vous me
dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire vous
connaissez la suite de l'histoire pour
les soins ou des gros bisous et beaucoup
d'amour et surtout de l'amour a très
vite
ciao
[Musique]